Oh back in my kitchen guess who's there  wow it's dim I work we just ordered Thai  food this is what we're doing on a  Friday night I just got done filming  this commercial for three days and Tim  just came in from Boston and I made oh  my god pickle teenies so I'm gonna give  Tim is first  well maybe not first but a pickle teeny  and see if he likes the way I've done a  pickle teeny okay so  I like it yes Jim is a [ __ ] about  pleasings can't say no I'm in light with  this yeah if this was Facebook Boop you  like this okay  all right Zuckerberg yeah so this is how  we're spending our Friday nights very  relaxing America and tomorrow we're  going to see her mom in South Jersey  which should be great Tim don't let me  keep you from eating your food and  you're starving go nuts  oh my gosh all right that's it pickle  tini time Cheers  look at this glass we just washed it  that's why it's through that start  making judgments oh it tastes like white  trash martini